I identify as a liberal because I was
raised by a super strong feminist mother
and I believe in equal rights for all
human being by a definition I'm a
conservative because I voted for Donald
Trump
the liberal policies are more humanistic
inclusive and less restrictive I believe
that my conservative values align most
with my morals
stated is I am nervous about things
nice topic sir I think they're really
sensitive to a lot of people and a lot
of people feel very strongly and a lot
of feelings get her and we see that in
society and stuff like that so I'm
nervous because like yeah we were
forming relationships like talking and
getting to know each other outside just
like now is it all gonna change like
let's hope not I personally think that
it's you in my pants your civic duty to
vote yep and I don't see why you can
complain if you didn't take the
initiative to well let your voice be
heard people should be going out and
making their voices heard and that
should be just general like what we do
because that's what we are supposed to
do as opposed to oh if somebody else
will take care of it oh it's not my
problem I don't know most of people I
know that didn't vote kind of non voted
their conscience and yet I think that
everyone should still have a say in the
right to be participating and I wouldn't
want to just silence
someone then they should be
participating that's not that's the
issue they aren't participants any value
in the local elections at all yeah
there's a lot of things other than
that's one thing so clearly my friends
do they go look I saw no value in any
local election at all zero nothing do
you guys do realize a lot of the people
being affected by Trump are people who
can't even vote so they're complaining I
might go ahead complain you've been here
since you were six five months old
you still can't vote or you're good tell
those people and they don't have a right
yeah that's it no I think those people
have a right to complain however my my
beliefs and my thoughts are pointing
towards people who are have the ability
ability to register to vote or to vote
and chooses you know yes I agree
wasn't you guys your premise that if you
can vote but people who cannot vote they
don't have that right that's for me so
that's why I disagree uh uh I'm not
gonna lie I didn't vote ha ha so all
y'all in the comments you guys can put
it in there now it wasn't my personal
favorite I'm not I don't agree with a
lot of the ways he conducted himself in
his presidential campaign but I think if
we look at him versus look at him from
before he was elected president he's a
very very different person we're not in
World War 3 so it's the hub the same
freedoms you still talk about and we can
still not like him though all these
things and think that he can't be doing
the worst job they're doing right now it
could be much worse I think he's doing
the worst job my thing is it's like when
did it be okay for him to be the least
common denominator when was it okay for
our president our the leader of this
country to be oh he's always not as bad
as he could be yeah I'll be honest I
didn't vote for Donald Trump but on
January 20th I said you want I hope he
does the best job just like any
President Obama did to you guys that I
hope he does because that's I have to
put my faith in the office of the
president regardless of run hold it
whoever that is they deserve my respect
the only reason I voted for him for the
primary reason was because Ben Carson
came out and supported that's how a
conservative would behave not gonna be
swearing he's not going to go through
divorces he's not gonna be on the news
saying stupid things that is what a
conservative person would look like to
me not like
we got yes I think the people of the
opposite parties are either missing or
more simply do not know better
I just think that people don't you know
you get different experiences so you're
gonna learn differently you're gonna see
things to be different through different
lenses like there is misinformation on a
lot of the conservative side you guys
have info wars you guys have things that
are blatantly saying Sandy Hook was fake
that the Hurricanes are to populate
climate change like that we have an
agenda as in like there's another reason
for us besides saving humanity to try
and do something about what we're
causing like just comes back through you
know what do you believe to be true and
why I think sometimes when I've had
interactions and people that disagree
there's so much emotion attached to it
and it's hard
I'm glad you don't think we're
misinformed by well I I think it think
she can see like I was listening Jen
when you're talking about the kind of
things that you feel the Conservatives
disagree upon or think about I think
you're discussing a radical set of
conservatism we generate what is
promoted is not but that is not what
most people are relating to if you add
if you would out but you're associating
yourself with those values so you in
what way so so that is value there you
have a white supremacist we're like
we're Christian you have unfortunately
but I'm totally that's not what most
people Ruth and your dicks and you
support white supremacist the same thing
with I mean most of those people are
great my biggest problem right now is
that each party is painted with one
broad stroke of everybody falls under
ten things challenge at least the reason
I didn't come in cuz I don't think the
other side is misinformed but I think
we're informed differently exactly it's
interesting social media allows you to
interact with people they're very very
different
you guys friend me on Facebook you see
I'm friends with more people that
disagree with me then agree with me I
don't care what you believe I'm really
really really interested in like a
it's like I believe this or why I
believe this why why why why and and
that's that's something that only
happens when you develop a friendship or
a lot of interaction
I'm proud to be in America and to think
about that a little bit it's like you
know you might love your child but not
be happy with how they're acting right
now and I see things that upset me and
embarrass me about how we are and yet
our possibilities the way we respond to
people all over the world or kind of our
values we're still proud but not maybe
as proud as I used to be there's a lot
of freedom in what you can say and I
think there's a lot of power in that
because I know a lot of people into
other countries if they say anything
about their government like they'll
disappear the next day and I get to not
only in voice my opinion but also live
it being able to do whatever you want to
do make who you want out of yourself
that's something awesome
I thought the idea of how this was going
to be that there would be more polar
rise more agreement and I see it more
centrist most people do a great motor
that's why I think Tom Porter's
represent all conservatives are all
Republicans no but that they're a big
population though but I think tonight
today I was pleasantly surprised at
everyone because I think that centrist
messenger maybe that I agree with you
but I also hold my beliefs and I respect
that I think that's something that we it
should be happening more and more
because I think there's so many
conversations where I keep me this crazy
person I talk to they think there's no
it's we disagree but that's okay I
didn't expect you to be super
argumentative or you know we have to be
uncivil about things because you know
people are gonna think differently and
if you can think for yourself and think
about the position you're in
it's very hard to argue somebody and
it's very very very very hard to really
dislike somebody just because they
believe something else but I was happy
to hear all of us it kind of be on the
same level really as far as social
issues like I mean as far as being
people as opposed to like this is my
side this is what I'm right uh you know
and that's much better I was pleasantly
surprised okay
the Facebook
[Music]